I do something called creating value you
guys don't know what value is yet by the
course maybe you'll learn what value is
you think I want money I'm doing this
for you I don't need your money he's got
all of these tactics man did a big part
of what they did teach is like you have
to go like when someone can't pay their
mortgage you need to go get it you need
to take advantage of that and if you go
out to the small towns the further you
get away from Toronto the more soft they
are and the more you can just take their
[ __ ] oh and take it hey someone's
parents died baby they can't make the
mortgage payments get up jump on them
this is what this guy's teaching he's
like you [ __ ] take care they're
lonely they're miserable put your foot
on their neck and take their money you
take it
Chapter three welcome to coffee break
coffee Zilla welcome to coffee Zilla
guys wrong Channel just drop the video
over on that side
Condit would definitely not be approved
over on coffee break welcome to coffee
Zilla where we have a special guest a
Trump University graduate now you can't
there's a lot I think that maybe a more
exclusive club than like a Harvard grad
there may be less graduates of Trump
University than any other clothes now
it's closed now you can't get this I
mean look at that's all we're getting
this money at Trump University I'm the
only one who's got it dude down shut
down I'm actually here to announce that
I'm gonna be selling this ten thousand
dollars at the end of today when you
first reached out to me oh just to set
the stage I I almost couldn't believe
that Trump university had graduates I
just assumed that like there was nothing
like that
like walk me through I mean how'd you
get in there what was it like give us
the experience man I'm sure everyone's
curious what a fun experience at the
time it was very stressful but now I
live my life in a way that like I would
I would do this for fun it's hilarious
looking back on it so my parents are
Gujarati they're from a state near close
Qudrat and the Gujarati newspaper around
here
they put an ad in Gujarati saying like
you got to check out Trump University
they I think they go for immigrants
because people are desperate for money
there they're just like my parents are
terrified because I'm becoming your
comic my dad's like this guy's never
gonna make any money in his life let's
go get rich and then you do your stupid
comedy [ __ ] that's basically what he
thought you'd already said hey dad I
want to be a comic he's like uh let me
send you the advertising this my parents
talked me into going it sounds weird my
mom's like yeah let's go see what it is
because they always do this free seminar
so we go to this hotel lobby near the
airport and eats all just brown people
I'm like why everyone only because the
guys running in wrong way and then we
run into come on we're in the people did
they were coming after our community
goddammit so we ran into a guy he's like
yeah you know like it's a tough economy
I don't know what to do but you guys are
doing good why are you guys on a
business already they're doing good my
dad's just being like weird whatever
right so we go to this thing the guy
like as soon as he starts talking he's
such a psycho he's talking about like do
you think they care about money you
think I want money I'm doing this for
you I don't need your money he's got all
of these tactics man I'm just like
everything he says the red flag me my
mom are looking at each other laughing
kind of and and we get to the end of
this thing this guy even does the
classic like he's like he's like it's
$2,000 for our real estate course now
here's the thing
I'm telling my dad like this is all
google-able
there's no reason to pay even 20 we can
get the book for 20 bucks at chapters
there's nothing else here they already
know I'm 20 years old I'm already like
dead I find it you're already ahead of
this thing I'm yeah I've always been
into scam [ __ ] too but but the Trump
real estate one we go there the guy's
aggressive he's like from hey he's like
a big real estate guy from Hamilton
Trump's not there they made it sound
like Trump could be there or he could
always do that they always give you like
a hint that the big names gonna be there
you may need to show up he might might
be a surprise guest whatever dude away
he shows up
slap is label on there and be done with
it that's it that's all he I think
that's all he pays for it cuz it's all
in the documentaries now like all his
scams but yeah no no they're not gonna
show up I remember I went to a thing
where Jarek Robbins was actually signed
up as a paid speaker he sent in a video
he's like sorry guys I can't make it but
check out my video instead and this is
Jarek Robbins who's 20 Robbins kid he
puts on this video of like man I was
down and out I've had nothing I was sure
I heard never could have stood on my own
two feet then I discovered that I gotta
get ahead in life Jarek
you are kidding me dude you know that's
so shameless but it shows you that they
all have the same story like the got
Tony Robbins kid has been some like like
like started from the bottom now I'm
here well in his defense it is the first
Tony Robbins kid that he left and just
married someone else so I think he
dropped his ass dude and these you know
they don't hook it up but he looks
exactly the same as him so the whole
time he's saying you're just like hey
call your dad man I said I started
humbly in the Tony Robbins organization
and I worked my way up like he talks
about that too how you said worked there
but anyway very similar like this real
estate scam guy very like aggressively
talking about it he's talking about it's
$2,000 for the weekend course he's only
trying to sell the $2,000 weekend course
they keep adding things to it like an
infomercial they're like you know what
we're gonna do guys to this today just
cuz you guys seem like a great crowd I
love the Gujarati community
I love your community and I know you
guys are gonna be real successful real
great in the business I want to get you
it I know Donald Trump wants to get you
and talk to him you know we're gonna do
we're gonna do a two-for-one two
thousand dollars two people one weekend
dollars it's all [ __ ] you can google me
my moment laughing you have that you
have this sales pitch so down because
they're always like to do just for today
just for this one moment I never do this
ever ever ever but in the next three
seconds if you sign up I will give you a
special deal that no one has ever gotten
before normally people pay two million
dollars for this worth but now for you
just for you right now
ten thousand dollars dude this guy is
fully on all the stuff
I love the Gujarati community so much
guys never guaranteed at the end of it
even does a thing of like you know what
though we only want really serious
people so we want people that are
serious about this come to the bag sign
up in the next 10 minutes and that's the
how they did the two-for-one
they're like the two-for-one only if you
do it in the first 10 minutes you wait
after the 10 minutes a yeah it's over
twofer one's dad 10 minutes after this
end and he's got 10 people at the back
just ready to sign us up right so I'm
sitting there this thing ends he's like
time to do time to go are you the kind
of person that gets it done signs on the
dotted line do you want change in your
life let's go it's all part is great
speaker I gotta say like very great
speaking quality things I was pumped up
just as a comedian I was like this is
amazing I'm gonna write a play about
this one day and I did but my life of my
my dad my so me my mom are kind of
laughing about it my dad is like let's
side you're never gonna make money sign
it up we're gonna go me and you were
gonna go so he signs up so that we could
go on the weekend me my mom are just
trying to be like no don't do it and
we're even telling him hey remember the
guy said 10 minutes or we won't give you
the two-for-one it's been 15 minutes now
dad come on if they take it now then we
know they're scamming he's just like no
no that's what they all do that's you
know he his whole thing was this is the
kind of sociopath [ __ ] you need to learn
you're in Canada very Canada yeah oh
yeah you're in Canada were sociopaths in
Canada too
oh hell yeah man I mean dude it's it's
such a similar culture for an adult baby
free market and and and you know in a
lot of ways we're living in the American
Empire man it's living in capitalism
it's the only way you can certainly you
can't be anything else and you know so
we're here we're in the game baby we're
in the game where the game goes on the
game if everyone else is sociopath
scamming I gotta teach my son how to do
this yeah I mean I mean you look at you
look at Dragon's Den it's a bigger it's
a Canadian show it's a bigger show and
it's like our apprentice so we're into
all this sociopath [ __ ] scams have
always been like you can yeah you can
get a bunch of Canadians and there there
is a softness here there is like people
are nice and like come on I said you
know buy the vitamin pills and it's
gonna help your house hey I want I want
to ask you about this because I've
always thought I've always suspected
secretly that the softness is a secret
it actually they can be just as brutal
as Americans is that true or false did
you actually believe that Canadians are
truly at their core nicer surface I mean
Canada's it's just different I mean but
but during World War two the the the
Germans were scared of Canadian soldiers
was their hardest [ __ ] there's some
hardest function to you know what I mean
World War two they brought the heat on
it but then after that it's been pretty
passive is the thing is the Americans
just you just keep one of these [ __ ]
Wars I mean look I'd come with you if it
made any sense but Iraq the second time
that's a [ __ ] pyramid scheme I mean
you got military at the top you guys got
the taxpayer you got the American
soldier and then you got Iraq is [ __ ]
done did every month another article
comes out like we [ __ ] them even more
than we thought they're so [ __ ]
they'll never come back because America
baby and they and and if you think about
it it is a you know it's it's it's it's
interesting these pyramid scans there's
a guy who wrote a book about that about
the founding of America and how the
whole thing maybe just the whole
capitalism the Oliver and it's a pretty
mainstream book I cannot believe the
number of people who fall for this stuff
it's like it is it is a scam as oldest
time have you heard of that guy like
Napoleon Hill like thinking Think and
Grow Rich so apparently that guy's like
like a yeah yeah you like that yeah that
guy's a lunatic dude I mean he was
scamming people with stuff way back in
the day he was one of the first course
sellers and his glasses are all about
like that's why you got to learn
something it's it's it's incredible and
that is the guy who started all the like
the overpriced overhyped courses and
then you know hundreds of years here we
are
people say that II he even was
influenced or I don't know if he was a
pastor but it actually comes from
Protestant stuff and Hindus have this
too but it comes from Protestant and
Hindus
have this like this like weird like just
work for the sake of work thing and it
it did I mean there's a book about it
I'll have to send you a link to it I
don't know enough about it right now
because I think I saw it last year but
there was a great book about this and
the guy was on like Big Think and like
some major shows but he was busy talking
about how America is kind of we're
easily seduced by that and it is there
was a country that just got bus I just
saw a great video from rare-earth it's
another YouTube channel about how a
country literally turned into a pyramid
scheme recently and everyone's just like
running out of there right now like the
whole country though Oh God involved
resident that's a WoW it was like I'll
send you the video it's a railroad it's
incredible it's safe here's what I've
noticed here's what I've noticed I mean
if you've noticed this - pyramid scheme
in the limbs
ohso pyramid schemes are kind of dead
they know as MLMs that were like we're
not pyramid schemes and everyone
eventually figured out wait you are a
pyramid scheme but now that's kind of
dying off more people know that you hear
multi-level marketing just get out yeah
oh it's all about the course selling
people have figured out oh this is great
how can you prove that my educational
product not working isn't just your
fault right yeah I'm just gonna say you
a five thousand dollar course and then
there's affiliate links so now I can get
you a Miche to sell other people courses
and then you get money and then I get
money and it's all everyone's gravy
again everyone's gravy and it's all
about the one of my favorite things I
ever heard is because here's the thing
this is for this is the old system made
by these real estate [ __ ] because
there's a thousand of these courses but
I remember I saw last year - because
we're doing this play for the Fringe
Festival I don't have to preface this
but basically there's this pickup artist
he's Canadian he's a pickup artist he
sells courses dude his courses same
structure as this and he puts all the
seminars online and it's just him this
this Canadian guy and he's just selling
again bunch of Indian kids who can't get
laid I guess pickup artist courses are
huge I had no idea I had no idea
Forbes Forbes are a real social dynamics
is called he's a he's a Forbes top 500
company yeah yeah yeah real social
dynamics yeah they're huge in there like
the
pickup artist game whatever all these
guys went to them and they're like
they're all about have you heard of like
nagging and stuff they like you know
telling about oh you're trash so they'll
like you're something it's become a part
of the cultural binocular like I've been
nagging on like sitcoms now so people
just talk so weird people are gonna get
brought it in yeah yeah yeah
people can defeat so go ahead good well
what I was gonna say is people gonna get
mad at me if that's not actually RSD who
brought that in so I apologize guys I
don't I'm not in the pickup artist space
here I always got a caveat because
people will call me out on this stuff
people studying pickup artists I'm like
hey I was doing a play it's called a
winner like mega Expo okay that's us
sure like no story this is the play as a
French play dude I was okay so this is
why this is why I started looking at
these pickup artists but then this guy
Morgan O'Shea he I did the play with him
he's gonna be like no but I was playing
the pickup artist I was actually playing
a financial expert he was the health
expert Faizal but this guy was playing a
pickup artist so then this guy goes why
are you looking at the pickup artist
though cuz you should be selling just
the financial name tell you why because
Jason capital bing-bang he's doing you
know Jason you know Jason oh oh yeah I
know of him yeah yeah yeah both and his
mentor Dan P is a Dan Pina his mentor
he's got this old man mentored that's
like [ __ ] he hits people dan Pina he
hits people he was on tour ogen trying
to tell Joe Rogan you gotta get my boy
Jason capital out here [ __ ] before I go
back to the strip thing I did want to
mention that since is the real social
dynamics guy so anyway this is why these
videos dude Jason capital you watch one
pick up our video then YouTube is like
oh we gotta lose you know who you are
yeah that's it
dude I'm running a TV show with a
feminist I opened my laptop it's like
how to get her panties
my laptop my my YouTube account
but anyway so anywhere all that's the
caveat of like no no no no is the exact
same thing happened to me
somebody had reached out to me a while
ago he was like some pickup artist guy
and he's like hey do you want me on your
show so I started looking him up and for
the next month I'm seeing all these like
pickup artist ads and I'm like dude I
get this off my yeah exact same thing it
happens so but one of my favorite things
that I saw this guy Tyler Durden he was
doing he was selling his he's a he's in
a seminar but he's in the free one kind
of like the one I went to with Trump
because they do a free one
yeah and then they pay they get you to
pay one state for one thing maybe it's
300 brothers maybe a thousand thousand
and then they start getting into like
the $5,000 $10,000 get [ __ ] boot camp
dude you go and you live with this [ __ ]
and you get Percy and that's it no why
it's guaranteed real quick I'm so sorry
we're like no they paid prostitutes to
to like hook up with some of these kids
really seriously it was expected was
exposed that like I'm not gonna say all
of them did it but one of these courses
where's like I'll get laid seminar they
would pay like just in case they struck
out they pay a girl to like not say
anything but then go back with them and
be like see this works in real life
where are the alarm bells from the
pickup artists community they should be
putting that guy out that guy should be
blackballed they should all be looking
at that guy's like get rid of him he's
not picking oh I think it was like
there's Watergate like that was like the
biggest like his youth problem that's
their Watergate dude someone's paying
it's like we have to clean up this whole
notion in the community they all got
together on there there but but this guy
but my favorite things he said he's
doing one seminar the buy-in seminar all
brown guys I wanted to do a reaction
video on it but I just felt that for
these brown guys they come up and be
like he's trying to be more confident
and this guy his videos on the internet
forever just a 22 year old guy named
Sanjay there's a video of you forever
and there's a guy teaching you how to
pick up girls
it's I I just felt bad whatever but one
of the best things I heard is this guy
talking
he's tell he's yelling at them all at
the beginning of one in one in summers
and he's like I do
thing called creating value you guys
don't know what value is yet by the
course maybe you'll learn what value is
I create value
do these roasting them dude he's ripping
on him to be like you better [ __ ]
sign up you little shits
we'll come on you just got eight hundred
dollars worth of value and now you don't
want to pay for anything why don't you
pay for the [ __ ] course you need to
reach in your wallet and pull out some
value
I left that it is as a comment on your
top ten red flags video cuz you're
saying your top ten red flags video of
like how does what a scam artist your
first one was mastermind and I put in
the comments valley I find value as a
big buzzword with these guys oh value
mastermind inner circle proven
techniques right like it's like yeah
over and over in the next 20 minutes I
mean it's it's the same stuff over and
over I may be Internet I used it it's
all that all this whole program is
because they've been teaching these
since the 80s there's one of these
classes you can find the infomercial
it's these two little people these twin
brothers they're both they're both
little guys so to you here and there I
[Music]
opened for Brad Williams when I was in
Buffalo and I was like hey we should
bring you you know he's he's a huge
comic dude and he's he's a little guy
he's a little so he sent the association
of Canadian like dwarfs and Kenner
whatever I sent them a thing being like
hey let's bring this guy in he's big
comic and you're like no he uses the
n-word we won't be working with him
inspiration
I always think that so I like I think if
you're of that class you get a pass no
matter what like I don't think that how
does that not make sense yes you could
say your word that's what I thought too
but I don't know see I look too white to
be able to say just to say anything so I
can't I can't even I don't even know if
I should have an opinion on any of this
even as a brown guy like I'm done to my
credit cards
white I'm half Cuban I mean it's like
but you'll never know I'm like the guys
in jail you know what I think you know
what they call it they call it white
passing I pass as a white person and so
therefore therefore all the privilege
all the privilege like you know that's
so [ __ ] that we do that baby and you
know to tie it back into what we're
talking about this is the thing with our
culture right now it is a lot of guys
that feel disenfranchised and feel like
they have no options in the economy and
these people look like they're thriving
right now like they just sound like
they're killing it right and and this
guy's the president look at them power
said no it's actually weirdly effeminate
like the way he like is his legs over
like that that's a little strange he
looks like he's gonna eat you man he and
if you watch his documentary and you
know I don't get too much into Trump
like we were saying this before it's so
just hacked it just make fun of Trump
right now it's like there's like 19
shows doing it right so but I do find it
interesting like I watch his documentary
it is like the come-up story of a super
villain and he buys these scams like he
basically bought this one he has his own
MLM company too and he basically buys
companies like this he's talking about
ACN I think ACN is Trump's or he owns
like the 30% 40% stake in it but in the
documentary they're saying that he
bought one of them and then started
because it cuz because someone makes an
MLM scheme and then there's the scheme
of like selling them to each other like
the owners of it they're like oh we're
merging these two MLM so now we're a
bigger network and we're gonna get more
whatever right so they Trump buys them
sometimes too so he's not only in this
real estate he's also in the MLM game
straight up and he'll buy companies and
then he'll just like start taxing them
so they it's like he's being given a
thing that makes a certain amount of
money but then he wants more money out
of it so he'll be like over having your
Commission checks this month dude that's
so crazy
that's so crazy that that was I I
actually my first MLM this is probably
pretty formative for me and maybe one of
the reasons I'm doing what I do now I I
was invited to this ACN scheme by a
friend of mine I didn't know what it was
about and I remember watching some kind
of show about it whereas like they never
tell you what it's what they sell
and so I go in there and I'm like before
I get in there I go
hey hey a friend of mine had brought me
there and his name was Mike okay I go
hey Mike you know what what do these
guys sell what tell you
and he goes he goes hey bro hey bro hey
bro you know you know we sell all sorts
of things and and you know I really just
want to before I tell you that I'll tell
you I'll get to that one second but
before I tell you that I want to
introduce you to my mentor to do you do
you know what actually what a
Lamborghini is you know the Lamborghini
is my mentor has 12 Lamborghinis in his
12 Lamborghini garage and you know he
makes millions of dollars a year so she
listened to him cycle so he introduces
me to that guy he's like this is my
mentor I go hey what's up how you doing
he goes hi nice to meet you you're a
distinguished friend of Mike or whatever
and I go okay well what are the what do
you guys sell because I kid you not I
kid you not
well we sell a lot of things and you
know honestly I mean it's a really
complicated business and I just want you
to listen to this one quick presentation
wait to the presentation wait to the
presentation we wait to the presentation
and Trump comes on and Trump comes on
you know he like goes hi guys I'm Donald
Trump and ACN is a great company and
it's wonderful in it and so afterwards
Mika's so what you think and I go well
what do you sell and he's like well you
know I mean we can get in that if you
buy but like dude it was mind-blowing I
don't think he understood what they
thought no they so hope they do they're
basically it is you're seeing a lot of
young men and you're seeing a lot of
seniors basically the vulnerable people
follow with people in our culture they
have a bunch of what do you call them
jackals just eating them trying to eat
them basically it's and what they're get
if there is a bit of value as we say
being given it's that a young generation
of men who don't know what to do with
themselves get to have a mentor and this
is a big part of what they sell they
like they like you need a mentor I love
the did you send me that one or should I
see someone was talking about like Tommy
must I hope as I get a mentor how did
you learn my Albert Einstein element or
Bill Gates had a mentor everybody had a
mentor you know
I let me go into this shot this place
it's a place of business
ego so what do you sell and the first
reaction is like hey hey hey don't be
dressed it took me three hours to not
get an answer
oh my god yeah I mean it's yeah there
it's it's such a it's such a con okay so
so let's go to now back to that Trump
universe so off-course so so we're at
this thing my dad's like let's get it
yes make sense we're all just even the
people that we knew from before they
were leaving like well I don't know like
they didn't buy it but they didn't
necessarily tell us not to buy it they
were like I don't know I'm just getting
a weird feeling about it I don't know I
mean these people from they don't know
they're not media savvy and they do just
trust white people I don't know it's a
thing come from India and they're like
don't they I don't know what it is it's
some shadeism some weird [ __ ] they just
have a hard time with that I find
they're just you know they're like well
make sense like even even news [ __ ] they
distrusted they just think like I'm me
shows in the newspaper how can it be a
scam it was in the gujarati times
how could a scam they wouldn't print it
it was in the gujarati times of brampton
my taxes yeah they would never scam us
whatever so anyway my dad just $2,000
dude he's like we're getting it and
that's it you never lose on education he
basically has this dream a dream that
like yeah you need to be a sociopath
like these guys so anyway go to this
thing it is just a bunch of weirdos I
know the second I get there dude within
5 minutes the first thing they did
before they taught us anything before
they did anything the first thing they
did is they said there's another $40,000
worth of courses that's the first thing
oh my gosh they don't even try to try to
no this is just the first million this
is
this is just like the starter cash
you're making on this this is just the
first million how you gonna take it hey
how you gonna take care of your legacy
that's their big if you create value you
can feel the legacy okay it's the bridge
it's the value bridge you build a bridge
from value to legacy bro this guy the
guy that was teaching her class he did
probably more time less time on actual
real estate knowledge again this is all
Google it's nonsense like just look at
how much is on one it's it's a waste of
paper look at what's on one paper like
this is you didn't even plan it you just
look to a random page and there's
nothing on it there's nothing on it but
a picture yes this is a picture the last
time I fit ok so here's here's a great
example
okay here's like a chapter thing what
does that say it says understanding the
foreclosure process so a big part of
what they did teach is like you have to
go like when someone can't pay their
mortgage you need to go get it you need
to take advantage of that and if you go
out to the small towns the further you
get away from Toronto the more soft they
are and the more you can just take their
[ __ ] oh and take it hey someone's
parents died they can't make the
mortgage payments get them jump on that
this is someone's children died and now
they you don't know what to do they're
confused but put your foot on their neck
take everything take it this is what
this guy's teaching he's like you
[ __ ] take it but then he gets into
his legacy talk where he goes what do
you think I want to do this for he's
showing us his airplane you think I like
airplanes what do you think I'm doing it
for land we're all trying to tell him
like is it the airplanes he's like no
it's not airplane what do you think it
is legacy legacy kill him who is this
like that okay if I could boil like sum
up the first weekend it's the real skill
they're teaching you is how to find
someone that's [ __ ] and then take
their [ __ ]
and they just have because they're they
should uniform but isn't that like a
microcosm of what they're doing to you
like they're finding people who do it
like are looking for a better life and
their take this is what even all these
type s course whatever there is a little
bit of technical knowledge of like you
know Amazon is it technical because it
changes all the time they don't
understand real computer programming but
they do have like okay
mostly what are they teaching their
basic saying the real money though is in
brainwashing a bunch of you idiots to
give me money and then you're gonna turn
around and brainwash another bunch ATS
to give you money and it's this
never-ending thing and that's why you
see like okay this is done now right no
there's a new generation of idiots and
another generation of idiots had
graduated to to take this [ __ ]
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding yep that okay
so that's the interesting thing about
like if you ever go to a Grant Cardone
10x conference okay so in this Quran of
ours you know he fired like half of his
staff I said the role in sales
commission no no he's like firing a
bunch of him and then he goes like oh
I'm not gonna give you your paycheck
unless and you can just go find a lawyer
your last paycheck you just go find a
lawyer and try to assume you want this
were allegations by his by his staff
okay so so but anyway so then he starts
he still has his 10x conference and his
10x conference is all in upsell so to
get into 10x conference you think you'd
learn something but it is just one giant
sales conference for everything else and
honestly it's hard to believe if you've
never been to one of these things where
it's like supposed to be about knowledge
and actually it's all about selling but
it's a crazy thing to behold because
you're like how can you do this yeah
it's great like it's so bizarre to me I
already paid two thousand dollars to get
value and you're just gonna sell to me
the whole time
it's so weird the best thing the best
thing is on the date so we pay the two
thousand oh I'm the day that it's
starting my dad doesn't even want to go
this is the
yeah yeah you go you go you're gonna get
rich man I can't wait for you to get
rich oh you go you got it my mom came
for an hour just to be like man we paid
for this [ __ ] so my mom came for like an
hour to one day but on the second day me
but the first day it you could feel them
getting their claws in your brain it is
a brainwashing session so I'm all
constantly fighting it I went in oh I'm
20 these people are all middle-aged Plus
though by the way yeah this is not the
younger crowd this is basically like mid
age crap middle-age crisis crowd divorce
crowd I'm gonna say because it divorce
and like you'd think and one of the
chapter two profits from real estate
look for a divorce because guess what
those vulnerable [ __ ] someone's got
their heart broken to them they're
lonely they're miserable put your foot
on their neck and take their money you
take it Chapter three
anyway chapter two find a divorce
chapter three take it take the bonus
session if you leave a testimonial then
at first you leave a testimonial saying
how rich you got from our course then
we'll give you the extra point five
seminar thing so here's the thing this
guy the whole day is just first five
minutes we got another forty thousand
dollars with the courses aren't you
excited
I guess what value we're here to deliver
for you we got another $40,000 with the
course aren't you excited
and he's got ten other people who have
already bought the course and there are
teachers so they're doing the beads like
like the in-between exercises there's a
couple of exercises but even just like
filling out a little stuff or like doing
some you know like like like financing
[ __ ] like there was little bits of
information of like show up to this the
two thousand dollar course no no no way
dude he's not showing up to any of it
he's not coming he's not coming they
didn't even give it to me
I think parties a university though
actually they just call themselves a
university that's it there's a good
documentary about it now shut down and
it's it's totally sure
this is it this is last one you can get
this believe that dude yeah you honestly
should just kind of I don't know it's
interesting because if you hold on to it
for the next election it may become
worthless if he doesn't get elected and
it may become more valuable if he gets
elected a second time and you could
really kind of leverage that value yeah
okay cool I thought you're gonna tell me
to start a course maybe well honestly
yeah you may start it you could be like
uh Trump's secret to getting rich dude
oh yeah the Trump of that out on my
brains working on the course uh how to
become president yeah Trump's guide
Trump's guide to become a dude he's a
president now how can you argue with
that there's a certain level of it to
where you can say whatever you want it's
a scam it's a done dude the boys rocking
the White House he took from day one he
taught in the course put your foot on
their neck and take their [ __ ] if you
watch his documentary yeah that's what
it is every episode of the documentary
it is the kinda straight back to Hillary
didn't he I mean Hillary was like
everybody thought she was gonna win win
win
you don't Trump doesn't lose he's gonna
win again in 2020 inviting so low-key
they did do that like the guy can't
perform it I saw an article and this is
real guys we won't stay on politics too
long cuz I don't like engaging politics
but this is too funny to me CNN wrote an
article called Biden's invisible
presidency and where they said the less
Biden has been showing up the better
he's doing in the polls because people
don't like see him like CNN right so
like CNN's like yeah if we can only just
keep Biden out of the television cameras
were fine like if I saw him weird
circumstance we actually have to talk
about him and the American people has to
see him were in were in deep trouble
ring look they spent all their money and
all their credibility putting Biden
right here and the more people hear
about him the more he just goes down and
down and and that's it
he's gonna lose drunk dude and like he
won the first time and if you look at
the documentary he eats people like if
you look at the Republican primary right
run it attacked
he's like destroyed you destroyed you
made a little dish on them hands like
Republican small last dig look at his
hands he's doing like this is like that
on them Hillary no Hillary can't take it
Biden can't take it no no for sure not
the second he brings up cuz nobody's
really addressed the dementia in the
room and he's gonna bring it up and it's
gonna be game over time because the only
thing people don't want more than a
trump presidency is a dementia
presidency President period yeah and it
looks like it might get kicked out
because of all this [ __ ] but hey to the
listeners don't blame us for bringing up
politics your boy became the president
yeah okay sorry sorry guys sorry guys
we're talking I just honestly don't and
we're talking about the roots here you
know given your just giving an honest
customer testimonial that's what this
channel is all about honest customer
testimonial of a Trump University judges
so so okay so you it's two days to
graduate two days two days for this
basics course I think the guy knew right
away that he's not gonna get me like I
was just so skeptical the whole time I
would I was cool with the other
salespeople now these other salespeople
they had bought more levels of the
course and so now part of what they
their education is they teach us for
free dude it's genius its mock abelian I
mean whenever I look at these schemes
I'm like this is brilliant though I hope
people understand like the beauty of the
hustle here there is a beautiful hustle
going on there's a beautiful hustle
going on these guys are losing all day
great yeah yeah yeah every lesson to
every lesson is a sales pitch every
lesson is like Marlowe story hey man I
got this now I'm getting married my wife
you know
and we just brought her for us so you
know I'm saying just buy her get the
course well if you like what you saw
here man you're gonna love course three
like he's just selling you on the whole
time he's doing his little side thing -
yeah yeah so they're just selling hard
um I'm just keeping my brain from going
crazy like these tentacles are coming in
my [ __ ] dad sent me here I'm 20 at
the time I thought I was a grown up but
when I see 20 year olds now I'm like
these these kids are not they're kids
they're not ready right so so I'm there
with a bunch of 40s 50s people and when
they start talking this is pretty [ __ ]
up [ __ ] starts coming they start asking
questions and then you know when someone
brings up like maybe maybe maybe like
we're not talking about this but they
start bringing up a divorce their
divorce you know and you're like okay
you're gonna take it there right right
every time someone put up their hand and
said something it was like a question
followed by a red flag that's it and
they go hi okay so the second time I got
corporate closed on my family had to
move into this thing can we fast-forward
and he's just paid 2,000 and he's
thinking about paying the 40,000 but he
just can't get out like they're just
stuck in this thing they keep it there
they're all repeats kanto people that
got scammed too and I think the
highlight of the thing was this woman
and this is another thing when you buy
the course you go to the front and you
announce it and you say like this is so
great but of course I'm so happy
yay I'm gonna do it with Donald Trump
we're all gonna do it we're gonna kill
it right right so this so this lady
[ __ ] hard close I'm doing it I'm
doing my own girl boss yeah sorry I'm
doing it so she's just so cocky the more
he put in handable our [ __ ] signs her
up her $40,000 but it's the 40,000 like
it to be fair everything is a 50% off
discount with these people so make up
40,000
still became like 25,000 because I do
remember that she got extra hourly
coaching so there's the cassette classes
but then if you want to get it really
learn the system and you want someone to
be with you you can pay extra for the
hourly we'll have a coach with you right
buy real estate with you if you honestly
they were selling you like if you can't
hate you need a sociopath teacher with
you cuz you can't like really put your
foot on their neck and crush it
we'll walk you through it hold your
hands we'll do it so she paid for the
full course and she got extra like
personal coaching and probably
twenty-five thirty thousand I remember
I'm walking in from the lunch thing
there just an incredible
so they get her money and they do this
is the best thing you can't just be like
hey I'm gonna sign up come make an
announcement no no no pay the money
close the credit card process let's go
hey don't trust you to follow through on
this at all that's the one of the one of
the things that I was like damn this
guy's so tight this is what made me
realize oh tight is that he's teaching a
class he's a good extra speaker like
he's selling really good stories it's
[ __ ] it's all motivational [ __ ] but
he's good at telling the story he's good
at he's got you in whatever but if at
any point you were touching a credit
card holding a credit card thinking
about whatever he can stop the story
let's go what's that let's close it what
are you waiting for
let's go why wait life doesn't change
unless you change okay like that life
will never change unless you change
it'll stay the same I don't need the
money I don't do this for the money I'm
not doing this for the money why do you
think I'm here right now I'm here to
help you yeah thank you someone someone
finally does a sign-up I was worried
about you guys this guy he's like so he
tried to pressure like two other people
into it and they didn't do it in the
morning but lunchtime I can hear her
she's scanning through credit cards she
goes up to do her announcement she's
like hey everyone I got the full course
and I'm very proud of myself
and okay okay okay this is it's gets
very emotional guys gets very emotional
when you make big life changes gets
emotional this is what we want we want
to break through here give it up for her
we're all clapping did
she's boy they just took her this is why
you have to be a sociopath to do this
how can you be somebody who cares if
you're like seeing this girl like
breakdown you know it's not gonna work
you know she doesn't she's not cut from
the same cloth as you you know now
here's the interest no sorry good no no
god please
well this is the interesting thing and
this is what the guy was talking about
in his book is that we cuz he was
talking about even North Korea like he
was talking about cults but then like
pyramid scheme called like dictatorship
they have this similar quality to them
where we want to judge people who are in
as being terrible people but really
they're brainwashed they've invested so
much they've bought in and they don't
know any better I remember I called okay
so I was telling you this is vector
vests this is think of Wall Street scam
thing that that we were getting at the
house who's that by who published that I
can almost guarantee I know who it is
okay well okay let's see the vector vest
smart investor replacing the confusing
blur of data with clear direction it's
basically like one of these market
predictions okay so there's a guy here
named dr. Bart deal little IDO just they
just have pictures of guys like this and
it that's I always do yeah yeah yeah
he's the expert and then like and then
on the back they have these like
testimonials like I just on you know I'm
a millionaire now look at their look at
their like you know I mean like this is
and it's very much for seniors
everyone's old in it everyone's like you
know they talk about retirement law like
what are you gonna do when you get old
because the truth of it is seniors like
and I did this in my play I did this
joke like I was playing this thing
financial motivational speaker and I was
telling the people in the play the
audience because we were doing it like
it was a seminar so I was telling them
like that I have an online poverty
calculator and what you do is you go
online you punch your numbers in and it
tells you what age you're gonna be poor
your and I'll say you're all gonna be
poor at like 50 I'll tell you that right
now
that's what the numbers dictate I mean
we have there enough so especially in
America America's even worse Canada we
are are our social programs are solvent
like they're financially whatever but in
America even that's a pyramid scheme so
even your old age security your
retirement plan the the money is not
there the money go on now yeah yeah you
know this is the thing with America is
that you you peel the layers off this
thing and you're like oh no that guy
like the owner of Herbalife used to be
the CEO of Disney or like to see you in
lower blood used to be the CEO of Disney
he's a legit CEO and he's running
Herbalife dude Herbalife in say it's
they they just take their only nice
because we have regulations here if you
look what they do in South America like
in any country where there's no
regulations they just you know you know
what they said about Mexico or our
company loves the blood we have the
blood of Mexicans running through our
veins we just love that it feels great
he goes he goes we've got the blood of
Mexicans running through our veins and
it feels great it's because they they go
to all these poor countries and guess
where the pitch of you know you're gonna
be rich really fast works best works
best in poor countries dude these people
are traumatized by poverty even my
parents like this is why they signed up
for this [ __ ] they've been scammed so
many times and it's it is always people
selling them this like almost reminding
them of like when I was growing up my
mom would tell me about like what if
there's a famine I'm like hey we're here
now be careful with that now we got the
corona virus I mean you know we're not
as far from that that used to sound more
far-fetched than it does now yeah but
you're right but you're right I mean
not a famine there's not gonna be a
famine even dude I know guys that grew
up in Iran and they have like these
fever dreams of like the [ __ ] Rockets
blood tearing up their Street and then
here they wake up I'm like maybe you're
here know happen there's no way that's
all over they're here we're good
but now we're becoming like this because
if we keep draining out like the real I
guess I hate to say value creation but
if we keep draining it out like there's
not gonna be anything left to keep this
side powerful you gotta have the value
dude you've got to have value a mission
that's the truth that I've been speaking
about for 30 tires is about you know
getting value and creating a legacy from
that value and you know what I say is
that you need to spend in order to get
rich and if you just bring your credit
card to the best do what's crazy is like
the stories I've heard about that credit
card thing it's by the way all of them
are set up the same because they've
really mastered what works uh what I've
heard that like it's almost unbelievable
it's a Dan lock what story where's the
guy who goes to the back and everyone's
swiping a credit card right everyone's
swiping for Dan and one of the guys
swiping for Dan is loaded swiping for
Dan describing for Dan and his credit
card won't go through and he's like
begging people around him to use their
credit cards like I'll pay back I'll pay
back I'll pay you back and then he's
like he goes he goes he goes if I could
sell my soul right now to be able to buy
this course I would
cuz his credit cards are all being
declined cuz he's already spent them on
all of Dan's other courses it's out of
money you haven't made the money bag
baby what are you doing dude it was he
was one purchase away from making it
it's a tragic story and Dan why still
does you talk to him if I just like sees
the guys like get security I don't know
this guy's a psycho dude dude do any of
them there's a kid who got a loan from
one of the people they're at a hundred
percent Interest I mean I don't quote me
on this whose something new something it
was something like this okay it sounds
like an agreement that a bunch of idiots
would make when they think like oh I'm
gonna be okay when I'm a millionaire in
two weeks I'll just pay you double this
right of course they're crazy of course
but think about
think about facilitating a loan
agreement at your own seminar to buy
your own course yeah and that's the
that's the biggest teaching and that's
what Dan Locke is teaching you to do
close the [ __ ] deal what's the
obstacle on the deal get around and
[ __ ] figure it out
they do have that mentality of like and
that's what inspires people I think is
that is that like why is a Donald Trump
so inspirational people you don't have
it in you to do what he does if you
watch the documentaries he's vicious man
he's so mean he like screwed his wife
like just for money dude forfeit he
divorced his wife publicly told the New
York Times cause a whole drama to save
like 50,000 that's like the second
episode only the for every episode it's
it is like I was saying it's like they
come up with a super villain and every
episode is like another boss that he
says I'm gonna [ __ ] eat you what are
you gonna do [ __ ] and the first episode
is the city of New York
he gets the mayor out he and he just
takes the money second episode is all of
the wives the women and just if people
think like I'm gonna be like this one
day you don't you don't have it in you
you don't have it in you and you don't
want to what a terrible thing to do I
mean you don't wanna do that it's a it's
a level of yeah it's it's brutality you
got to be willing to be brutal yeah yeah
and they really so I gotta send you that
that that country the full country
became a pyramid scheme it's from this
country uncle rare-earth it's it's not
as you know and this is what I was
bringing up about this where we look at
the people in there as like terrible
people but actually we should look at
them as people who are brainwashed and
they're lost and I don't know I switch
back a little bit let me push back a
little bit I think part of that's true
but I also think it's a very it's like a
my it's like kind of a Western mindset
to think that like people just don't
have the proper understanding because of
a lack of information or something like
that and I think sometimes that's true
and sometimes it's just true that
they're actually they actually do know
you know they actually do know exactly
what's going on like I was watching the
Panama papers like it's this documentary
on the on these like ultra rich guys who
offshored all their money and like
Jeremy
Corbin's one of them and he's hiding all
his money off shores but in the same
breath it's like a British what he was
he was he was okay so in the same breath
he had spent all this time campaigning
about how dare people go offshore and
hide their money this is sick this is
sick that the ultra wealthy can do this
and I for one won't stand for and then
like two years later or something like
that he's done the exact same thing so
you can't say in that case oh he's just
brainwashing into the system
no sometimes people know exactly what's
going on and they're doing whatever
necessary to get ahead regardless yes I
mean you're top level I mean it does
become its own pyramid your top level
are the real wolves and I think I heard
this in one of these Tyler Durden
speeches which by the way Twiggy what's
up with the Tyler Durden name when it's
like isn't that the goth Fight Club guy
yeah yeah but there is a guy named Tyler
Durden no he's the owner of the this
pickup artists company that was on the
Forbes 500 it's called real social
dynamics he's got all these motivational
speeches he's got big I think he has one
called where he explains this philosophy
a little bit where he's like there's
either wolves or there's sheep you're
joining my company so that I can train
you to be a [ __ ] wolf and if you
don't make it took your money I mean I
don't think he says like then I just
took your money buddy it's just kind of
implied they're like they're teaching
you to be a it's a class to teach you to
be a sociopath if you can go all the way
then you're the vicious sociopath at the
table you're basically joining like a
little game of Thrones of your own
little thing but everyone below them
like when I call these guys and say hey
you know stop sending this [ __ ] to my
dad you know he's buying [ __ ] some
pill this the one that I got from sorry
that the medical company guy I had one
years ago it had a picture of Jesus
sitting under a tree and the guy said we
got if you eat the bark of this tree
arthritis bing bang bang and say god is
great because your arthritis done
because jesus said on the tree under the
tree and meditated for something prayed
arthritis done
so all these seniors they're buying this
[ __ ] and and so yep I open the thing and
I called one of the seniors I called
their helpline they had like a little
number helpline
I'm telling her like what are you doing
whatever whatever and then I realized
five minutes in that like nirodh she's
brainwashed in and she lost her money to
this this alrighty you're right you're
right it's the it's the people in the
middle that don't know what's going on
that's that's the real sheep and the
people at the bottom that really get
[ __ ] like but it does get existential
where you're like what is what is
capitalism and this guy makes a more
clear point about this in his book but
like let's just say something like the
military-industrial complex
you've got a bunch of people getting
rich off of it at the top and you know
that's pretty obvious there so there's
the CEOs there's like the guys that have
to get lobbied in the government that
get paid off whatever some send it and
then below that you have your senators
your car factory in my district and
whatever whatever and you got those ceos
of those military coming then maybe you
like the american people who have to pay
20 percent of your tax dollar goes to
military I don't know maybe 15 something
plus a ton of debt to China so there's
they're paying for it and then below
them there's the American soldier
they're coming back with PTSD they have
no [ __ ] health care when they get back
to they only give them health care when
they go when they come back the US
veterans are [ __ ] on health care and
then at the bottom you have Iraq and
like what's what's the difference this
is a pyramid scheme in a way you know or
is that a stretch what do you think yeah
dude it's it's so tough because a lot a
lot of things they can have some kind of
an effect I mean it's kind of you can
get into a cynicism where you're like
everything's a scam everything's a
pyramid everything is just like this
like giant rip-off game but sometime I
mean I think from a certain perspective
you can kind of look at everything that
way but I cannot live my life like that
I have to say that like okay some of
these definitely are worse than others
like a good example is what you talked
about with like the like using religion
to buy be like get people to buy like I
saw I saw another one which is like hey
there's a secret cure for cancer snuck
in the Bible in like the Gospel of Mark
and you know our doctor who's who's you
know the Big Pharma wants to shut him
down but our doctor he's willing to be
the rogue wolf who will tell you the
truth and for only nine ninety seven
he'll tell you the truth okay
that is I can easily call a
black-and-white situation of like yo K
you're taking advantage of people there
is no value here there is no value yeah
who's there terrible word but there you
know is there value to having a good
military yeah I mean maybe it's a little
overblown sure like let's just say that
let's just say the same there's a
there's a there's a right-wing movement
that lobbies the government to say go
into Iraq they believe like I mean even
even there's people there there are
right-wing people in America that
believe the end times is gonna come if
certain people are here and you know
have you seen any of that stuff with
Vice like they do these documentaries
about that so I have a question do you
think do you think that at any point
someone was like let's at the top let's
go to X place because it'll make us
money and that's the only reason well
okay so the interests are tied up and
and when one of the one of the famous
presidents I think Eisenhower when he
left his presidency his last speech
there's a famous speech that he made you
could see it on YouTube he said watch
out for the military-industrial complex
it's a marriage of like people looking
after your best interests but also a
bunch of rich people a ton of money
people that are committed toward people
that are committed to a certain way of
life kind of brainwashed into it and
they are going to have a bigger and
bigger hold on our government now if you
think about after World War two why the
Cold War even happened the Cold War was
partially an American fear of communism
coming back which in hindsight a lot of
people say was a little bit overblown
especially with Joseph McCarthy and all
that stuff but a lot of people will stay
a bunch of companies that were making a
ton of money during World War two
because you build your wealth during war
if you're the one if you're the winner
so like while Europe is going broke
this is how America became a superpower
they're kill each other going broke
America joined the Brits because they
lent them so much money that they're
like if these guys default on the loan
we're [ __ ]
we're losing all this money so they came
it that's when they came in late and
everything so they came in to back
England they because they were playing
both sides they really kingship to
Germany like Hitler they were working
with Hitler too but in the end they you
know it's moral to they what may
probably wanted to go with the
english-speaking and not a [ __ ] Nazi
so they basically in the end went to
England but a lot of it was because of
money so one
that happens you have a country where
what percentage of the economy is war
and what are we gonna do next because
we're just gonna close everything the
Middle East I mean Russia might you know
their communist they're gonna expand
what's Vietnam I mean Vietnam is just
such a traumatic event in American
history and it is something that you
know I recently heard one great I think
Graham Hancock he was talking about how
like how twisted it is to think that
it's okay to just go into another
country and occupy them like no we think
it's normal but it's kind of [ __ ] up
like a bunch of people get rich off for
this and we're all just kind of part of
a system that allows it so I don't think
nobody anyone it's a mixed interest some
people are religious and they think some
people really believe in it Charlie
Wilson he's an American senator he
really wanted to help Afghanistan and
his movies great
Charlie Wilson's War he really wanted to
help them he said we got to back these
people they're nice people they're
getting attacked by Russians let's help
whatever yeah there's a there definitely
is also a thing of by the way you know a
lot more about this than I do
I did not expect to have history
unpacked here I love it I people are
gonna really enjoy this but I think that
there is a streak of moralism here where
we think okay these we know what's best
for these people it's not to have this
system of government and maybe they
can't help themselves get out of this
system of government because they have
no way to overthrow it so we'll kind of
play the role of God a little bit here
in this country and well displace this
autocrat or you know whatever and we'll
replace them with our own guy or or some
guy that they like I think that's always
our intention but I think well not
always but the main ear and a lot of
times a lot of times that that goes way
back way so yeah I mean with Iran I mean
it was pretty clear the the guy in the
CIA who did the mission he puts out TED
talks now you wrote a whole book about
it
it's like Declassified I think but he
basically says like we basically
overthrew the government he ran a
democratically elected government we
overthrew them because the he was going
to take the oil back and we need
like yeah that's you don't know we own
the oil it seemeth SATA to the Saudis
right like why why is America helping
Saudi Arabia they're vicious man they
have slaves in there
you do realize hey you do realize at
some point when there's enough money
somewhere we lose track of our values
like you saw it with the MBA in China
like remember remember what everybody
the NBA was like freaking out like how
talking to China because there's just so
much money there that we can say all we
want about freedom of speech but as soon
as like China says like wait actually
we're not gonna let you in here anymore
it's like everyone hits their knees no
like yes yes no Chinese our new overlord
I mean they have been number one for the
worth for thousands of years and they
are on a practical back there they're
coming back man
they're making power moves dude they're
buying they're buying the world they're
they're colonizing in a sense you could
say okay so this is what they're doing
right now they have this new belt in
road initiative they basically go to a
dictator they say hey let us build this
port and if you can't pay back the loan
we'll just own it for a hundred years
the way these Brits did with Hong Kong
so now they have important in Pakistan
they have a port do they have them in
Europe they have a grease port they just
own the [ __ ] I mean with Greece i think
Greece still have might have a chance to
pay them back but I think they actually
defaulted and China just owns I now so
they have China this isn't real anger
they have a port Pakistan they took over
to bed you know in my lifetime they
[ __ ] took it man they went into bed
and said you're not [ __ ] Tibet you're
China who the [ __ ] are you do i la ma
you know what he's gonna do this [ __ ]
this using ping he's gonna pick his own
Dalai Lama he's like you don't know who
like he's born in China we got him they
got a llama
it is crazy that some somehow dislike
this mentality of get power or money by
any means possible that you see so
clearly in scams does kind of bleed into
a lot of other things
well it's cult leadership it's it's
called it's dictator cuz dictators have
to operate with the same thing and
that's why I know it sounds kind of hack
again to call Trump Hitler I know it's
so hacked like everyone calls every
Hitler it's so hacked but he is doing
that kind of stuff where it's like if
someone doesn't agree with him they get
fired you know what
like he wants just complete control but
but no I don't think he's that I don't
think he's that bad
I honestly think he'll win 20 20 I feel
like that's offensive to say that he's
not that bad
I mean look the American establishment
is so not it is so not offensive to say
he's not hitler'd that's so like I don't
know why that's like the place people
jump because they always every time you
say that you have to backtrack otherwise
your life everything's Hitler not real
yeah it's a little hack don't just call
everyone Handler then it loses value
then it's just [ __ ] oh my boss got
mad at me for being late Hitler's the
new literally you know how like people
are saying it literally a lot and like
it's never mean literally yeah it's like
I literally died yesterday it's like no
so so what people do I find is that is
that they'll take something that's the
left wing a little bit and they'll be
like what are your Communists and then
they'll take some that's right wing a
little bit be like this guy's Hitler and
there is like he is making those kinds
of moves where he's just gonna run
everything he's gonna take all the money
for himself I mean I got a city this
rare-earths documentary the the the the
country he's talking about it's an
Eastern European country and they
basically the the prep the Prime
Minister of the country was in on the
scam but they all believed it as a
country they were in a scam here's what
amazes me about Trump and I guess we've
kind of have we covered though you we
fully explained how you became at Trump
University grad we got to the end of
that story cuz I just kind of want to
spin yeah and that's other things my end
of that story is look I'll just say this
I never bought I'm proud of myself I
really held that out and my dad never
brought it up again it just kind of
fizzled out my mom knew - she came in
for two hours the next day it was just
very choked but everyone that signed up
was in really permanents a good into
that so I wanted I wanted to ask you
this I wanted to ask you this what
amazes me about Trump okay so I've spent
a lot of time thinking about like how
apologies work how non apologies work
and how people get away with stuff first
not get away with stuff it's very clear
in our society that people screw up all
the time but the outcome of that screw
up is so wildly to
and Trump exists in this like weird
class of nothing nothing affects him and
it's fascinating and like it's like it's
a superpower it's actually his he's like
ultimate superpower is that nothing
sticks to the dude doesn't give aha
Wow give a [ __ ] and I'll tell you this
all these [ __ ] courses that's what
they teach that's at the foundation of
it is like hey what are you afraid to go
tell your mom to buy tell your [ __ ]
mom to behind you got 800 boxes of pills
in the garage your mom doesn't need him
ins tells your mom get her on the phone
[ __ ] closer close that [ __ ] we're
between head amun [ __ ] interplay in a
French plate we put like closer close it
I don't dude that's and they're teaching
you and then the pickup artists guys
they teach you this too and you were
mentioning egging but a big part I find
with them is like who gives a [ __ ] you
see someone hot go up let's say what's
up baby how you doing don't see what's
up baby but like whatever it is say hi I
mean their whole thing is like stop
giving a [ __ ] stop giving a [ __ ] take
what you want
really but I mean paradoxically there is
something really attractive about that
people like people who don't just bend
over every time they get in trouble
that is something yeah and the most part
as they get older I realize the most
profound truths are contradictions so
the answer is not simple in the West we
do have a mentality of good and evil one
sides right one size wrong but in the
East they have this yin-yang kind of
philosophy where everything contains its
opposite kind of so it's almost like
even with left-wing right-wing politics
the further you go this way the further
they're gonna go that way it's almost
like this equal and opposite it's almost
like a reactionary thing more than who's
good and who's evil it's it's like cuz
cuz they go around and make become kind
of the same thing at the end I find with
a lot of a lot of very like like you
even think of all the contradictory
sayings like look before you leave but
if you hesitate you're lost so it's like
which one is it and the trick of life is
finding that balance I guess so now with
something like this it's like hard times
will
for all of us and we need to be strong
to write like yeah yeah and you're
seeing a lot of like right-wing not
right-wing Blake on that side backlash
of like this generation is getting soft
we need to toughen them up we need to
make sure they're get do they do you
want like even conservatives are like
are you getting [ __ ] though like they
wanna go like this looking this uh
this or this dan Pina guy he's all about
like get money [ __ ] like do take what's
yours this is how you're meant to live
this is how the Lord wanna you live in
abundance and this is how no no at the
same time if times get tough you have to
have some toughness to you you have to I
mean even even if even something as
simple as like picking up girls if
you're single and URL and someone's cute
I think you should say hi that's how I
was raised I have two older sisters
they've always told me don't [ __ ]
stare at people go say hi or mind your
business different mean it's not wrong
now at what point does it become like a
little big of artists I mean it's like
yeah that's why that's why I feel like
cancel culture is a little [ __ ]
night and I do think that we are making
a big mistake
when we try to ignore things or we try
to just say like just even with Donald
Trump winning all dude I'm dying to talk
about this cancer culture thing [ __ ] on
are you about to continue talking about
the cancer culture thing I was gonna say
that just be real quick with with even
if somebody going from it's almost like
during the election people were like
we're not don't even look at him we're
canceling him he'll never win don't look
at him we're canceling him he won idiots
and he won every [ __ ] step of the way
are you crazy every step he'll never win
this thing he won it heeding that he'll
never beat Ted Cruz one at a time one
primary at a time one person at a time
he just picks a target and he takes it
out people want it Trump is a great
example as people want to talk about him
like he's so stupid call him evil if you
want don't say stupid his instincts are
tight he's sharp
there's a lot to I had learnt even
watches documentary there's things that
you need to pick up on even if it's just
to know when someone else is doing it
even if it's to know that if two of you
are going after the same thing bring
some heat on it well however you got to
do it but be aware of it don't pretend
it doesn't exist because I do think
that's a big failure of the cancel
culture dude III first of all I cancel
culture he's this weird thing that I
struggle with okay because on the one
hand I made a video long to like a year
ago
about how bad public shaming isn't it
cuz I read one Jon Ronson book and then
this other book about social norms and I
was like oh yeah this is really bad but
then I noticed the fake gurus and nobody
was calling him out and I was like well
let me publicly shame these idiots and
so like then then I made a bunch of
videos sort of like calling out people
but there and what I realized is that
there has to be a balance on the one
hand should we just in people's careers
because they've done one thing wrong no
and like if people apologize one of the
biggest things that I hate is there's
this big like questioning all the time
of you know oh you didn't mean that
apology so we're never gonna forgive you
and it's like I feel like you have to
give people the opportunity at least to
be better otherwise there's nothing
anyone can do ever like we live in a
weird time where no one can mess up I
don't think that but on the other hand
do we just anytime someone gets caught
out do we just say oh no no no we're not
gonna publicly [ __ ] we're not gonna
cancel them because you know that's just
too toxic it's like no people do dumb
stuff that the Justice Department will
never pick up on they'll never prosecute
you can't rely like people think they
live in a world where justice always
wins without ever it kind of existing in
the court of public opinion I think a
lot just has to happen in like the press
people have to be caught out on their
stupid stuff and you know yeah I mean I
think the press is like the first step
to police action you know and and this
is definitely a controversial opinion
too but it kind of happened with with a
lot of the me to accusations you make
the accusation okay and you want to say
like I'm with her okay I'm with her but
also if you don't have the evidence on
this we can now look back at several
cases and say you're not gonna convict
them so what is it gonna be it's gonna
be a public shaming now with someone
like in Canada we had Jian Ghomeshi who
first of all he built his career being
this [ __ ] lefty loser I never liked
him god I
never met a dude who like Jian Ghomeshi
he was a creep from the beginning it was
all these girls that were telling me
like you should listen to young Ghomeshi
he knows he knows feminism oh and who's
just punching a girl in the face and
[ __ ] being a psycho
it's him obviously of course he's so
then they go to court with it which and
I fully support and I believe that he
did what he did but in this particular
case like the evidence wasn't there so
but I still think justice was done in
the Jian Ghomeshi case because he's done
he built his career being this lefty
[ __ ] bleeding heart feminist lefty
and then he ended up being a guy who's
hitting girls so that works now you look
at someone like Bill O'Reilly okay
Bill O'Reilly does this [ __ ] now he just
says do YouTube at home you hooked a bob
did he that hunger YouTube there's
[ __ ] hookers in the back this he's
waking up ok so ad guys get these
Muslims they're coming in here and I
don't like it like he's just no he's
probably making more money oh my gosh to
sell a gold ad or whatever the [ __ ] they
do they're like so I mean it's
complicated you're not always gonna get
to the justice without like real proof
and without real like a legal standing
about it you might not always get
justice and at the same time there's
things in the justice system that should
be fixed for sure like there is a
balance with canceled culture to where
you want people to be caught out and in
some ways it's a good thing that stories
can get out but at the same time and
this is why this is like how I try to
balance it you need the other side so
like if I ever say anything about a guru
on my program anybody can come on my
show and try to argue me tell me why I'm
wrong and if I am wrong I'll just take
the video down that you'll never see it
again or I'll issue some kind of a an
apology because I just yeah you just you
have to give people their other side of
the story I think that's what happens
with canceled culture is like one side
says their side and we go okay okay
we've made up our mind you're gone yeah
that's all the issue or the other guy
gets to say his piece and say wait
actually I didn't do this or here's the
full story or and we've already made up
our mind and that's so I think we have
to adapt to that and get to like a place
where okay
for we decide let's hear both sides and
then you can make up your mind yeah and
I think we need to be more like like
again I guess just not as like not so
triggered about it like don't okay
you can't talk about this issue without
saying some of these words whatever like
you can't trump this happened - it goes
back to that thing of like how can you
even look at that it's like one day
you're telling me to watch me uncle
Messi and then the next day it's like
how can you even look at that just lets
live in reality and just say what
happened and that's it there's too much
of this like why aren't you thinking
like I think why aren't you shutting it
all out and a lot of times they get
their credibility from this like
something like let's say Alex Jones
right I would say Alex Jones gets a lot
of his credibility when someone on the
Left says do not talk to him how could
you talk to him that's where the
credibility comes from now in the end
they got him out over YouTube but I
think they build him up
that's they brag about that a hundred
percent and even YouTube censoring him
now he goes well I'm the most censor guy
in the in the world like you dude I mean
it's a shout out directly from YouTube
like they're just saying this guy's too
dangerous to listen to doing now
everybody wants to you know hear what he
has to say in some circles he's like
this like hero sort even though you know
it doesn't mean his ideas are any more
correct than anyone else it just means
you know that he broke some policies but
he he speaks good man I mean he speaks
good is crazy he's so funny he's he's so
funny but but but he is he's troubled
and he's clearly suffering from some
mental illness and this is what I was
saying before even about like he's a top
guy but I still almost look at him like
a victim because he's like dude have you
met someone who's into conspiracy
theories they're [ __ ] up the whole day
it's just you see that you see what this
guy even Joe Rogan tell stories about
hanging out with Alex Jones Joe Rogan
would be like yeah we're at a bar we
order drink the surfer walks away Alex
Jones like you see what she said there
she said she's a thank you they say like
he's just gears are grinding all day do
your taxes that make into meters
contractions making too much connections
as like oh yeah yeah yeah I mean
it is that with him it is like a mental
illness even I know this is - this is a
lot because at some point and this is
very like Eastern philosophy
it's very Buddhist but it's like in sam
harris says it's - actually because sam
harris says that in the future our
prison system is not gonna be about
taking revenge on people it's just gonna
be about correction it's just gonna be
about like your thinking your wrong way
and you gotta stop thinking like that
and i think that's the the attitude we
should have with these guys I love that
h3h3 productions called out ty Lopez and
then they got together and did a thing I
love it yeah I think that's that's all
you can do man keep putting out the [ __ ]
saying he's a scam he keeps saying no
I'm not let the people just cut like
there's some things you gotta just let
it trickle out and we have to just raise
awareness alula absolutely I don't
believe in this bloodthirsty thing I
think that's where it goes wrong where
it's like we know let's in this guy
everybody let's get in here go pitchfork
put your boot on his you know on his
neck and ends up taking I think that's
where it goes like way too far and uh
and and and you know I think if we do
too much of that to what becomes popular
what becomes the only way to deal with
like times of crisis is never
apologizing and doing the Trump thing of
like I didn't do anything wrong total
denial because if I don't deny you guys
gonna eat me alive and so I have to I
cannot be better because literally you
guys are gonna kill me if I admit it so
therefore I will admit nothing ever at
any time and like this is what you see
with all these institutions is a lot of
them are learning in times of crisis
admitting you're wrong and reflecting
will be met with hatred and not saying
anything I'm like not anything is just
avoiding the problem will be met with
some hatred but mostly like people will
go okay well they didn't address it so
we don't really know what's going on
well encouraging people to do nothing so
here's here's the scary thing that I
tried it to help people you the cancel
culture you're you're only canceling
your own people you're cancelling the
soft targets he us nice guys like us who
would never hurt anyone will get
cancelled for [ __ ] saying a word on
the other side they're [ __ ] there
they're like on the right right like the
so much to cancel them like think about
Trump right how much has he said it's
nothing he can say that would cancel him
okay comet can't say what he says a
mid-level comic will be like you're done
with Chappelle they're trying to cancel
him yeah with louis c.k I guess he's
making his inroads back but they're just
like never again never like all these
guys Aziz Ansari survived because he's
brown I think like even him Aziz Ansari
the only one that six months later I
turn off my Netflix Aziz Ansari comedy
special I'm like ooh that's gotta hurt
on that girl that called him out a they
just made him a comedy special and a new
show but no actually actually I've got
to talk about that because that's such a
weird situation cuz that that is a case
where before his story came out everyone
hated him and then it turned out that
what the girl said wasn't exactly what
had happened and that it wasn't exactly
as bad as what it was it sounded like in
the press like it sounded like it was a
true me to story and what it ended up
being is that it was sort of a confusion
about like intent and stuff like that
and or that's how it sounded to me but
still Aziz Ansari I had to like address
it and like there was this very
seriously before you can make it back
you've got to like you know do this very
serious
where was it like the same level of like
hey I'm just gonna take what I want from
you and yeah but I think that's the
solution man because at the end of the
day I think that's a good move because
we're here to do our work right so just
do whatever you got to do to do your
work and like I have to go through this
as a writer too I'm writing in Canada so
like it's like I said one time I opened
my laptop the [ __ ] all the suggested
are like how do [ __ ] get [ __ ] in two
days guaranteed turn number one
technique I'm sitting through the
feminist she's the [ __ ] are you watching
did you see this it took a whole month
to clean that out I did go on each one
and be like I'm not interested in this
but but it is weird that we take these
subcultures even pickup artists even
this it's like we we there is this sense
of like just pretend they don't exist
and it's like you're pretending they
don't exist so you're giving them a
little circle to be psychos in like
Trump like Alex Jones you're basically
saying you're not part of our
culture so they're saying okay [ __ ] you
then I'm making my own culture and I'm
the king of my [ __ ] culture I don't
give a [ __ ] I'll I'll be honest they're
like like I first of all I lean super
independent I kind of hate both parties
which is such a cheesy thing to say but
like but that's just the way it is but
I'll give the right-wing this they troll
the left so hard and it makes them like
sort of win in a sort of weird way it's
like it's like the side that cares less
and is looking to just like just like
dumpster the other side they kind of win
the culture because it's like it's funny
it's entertaining and it's like whenever
I see like these like like left they
take everything so seriously everything
is the end of the world everything has
to be like top we all have to care about
this issue all the time and I did it's
all about shame shame it's not good for
you yeah
a lot of shame the weird obsession with
uh with money and this is like Grant
Cardone saying he's like you're a loser
if you're not a millionaire what a
spirit dirtbag if you don't have enough
money for every single kid your kids are
ever gonna have if you don't have that
legacy bill you're a loser who needs to
want more and he's like he built this
thing where it's like having money is
moral and it's immoral not to basically
spend your entire life chasing as much
money as possible all the time he's very
prosperity gospel he's a he's like a
Joel Osteen but without God with
Scientology
yeah with Scientology is he sad oh yeah
he's a Scientologist yeah he's big-time
and anytime like anyone brings up like
the Xenu he's like well I don't care
about any of that I just I just I know
it's helped me and all these you don't
he's doing he's like he's like it gives
me access to all these sheep because I
need customers like he's just in there
converting people - no I think I think
I've gotten the impression that he
really no he's all about it he's all
about the getting audited all that stuff
yeah Wow
did you see his his episode with oh dude
there's a great channel that you'd
really like this British guy he's like a
sales guy and he's doing a similar thing
but he goes through he he went to the
seminar you money think we incurred like
well I know my yeah he's great he's all
that sick man
now I'll check it out so it might win it
played a clip of Cardone on Jordan
Balfour show and them sparring and you
could even see with them they're like
Jordan Balfour like like a piece of [ __ ]
in a lot of ways probably like he is the
wolf of Wall Street yeah like you watch
that movie it's it's it's three hours of
like celebrating this guy's psychopathic
life and then five minutes he's in jail
and then you turn on YouTube and Jordan
bumpers like I'm out of jail and I'm
selling the course let's go people let's
go and he brags about it he's under he's
like he's like wolf of Wall Street came
out boom maybe I'm back in the game dude
that brought him back big time you know
that is the story I am some point wanna
like cover how long people that are
white-collar criminals go to jail
because it's almost never and it's
almost for no time at all like if you're
a just any kind of normal criminal throw
the book at you the second you like run
it so if you rob a bank like the normal
way of like with a gun
you're in jail so much trouble if you
rob a bank by like fleecing customers
yeah give you a pass is the American Way
hey man it's okay you know the best
gildo the best jail is that epstein jail
dude first time Epstein for his [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude was like you get cool place
honestly it's pretty well well taken
care of I like someone else taking care
of my laundry but you know I go on my
saturdays free Saturdays dude I know
you're talking about that second jail
that second jail he got put in was no
joke the first jail yeah the first time
you got caught it was just like an
optional checking check in three days a
week you're good I have to mention this
one thing real quick this is where it
gets me though these conspiracy guys
every now and then they have a point
it's rare it's but they have a point and
you can't totally this is the
frustrating thing I wish you could just
totally just miss him and be like oh you
guys are crazy enough but they're not
totally crazy they're just skeptical
people who don't believe anything and
sometimes not believing the official
narrative make some sense like when
Epstein has all these secrets of you
know of these like giant heads of state
and stuff like that all of a sudden he's
gonna backflip off his bunk and kill
himself with like a bedsheet I I don't
think so
his guards happen to be off duty like
it's just too much was going on and I
kind of feel like every now and then I
feel like people in power are just
flexing on the American people a little
bit and I felt like that was a flex
because it's like we can take this guy
that you know has all the secrets and
we'll just kill him and we'll get it all
ruled a suicide but I don't even know if
it's a flex as much as just they're
terrified of like this guy's got dirt on
me
that's what they did yeah they were
getting Clinton dude they were getting
these rich powerful people [ __ ] 15
year-olds so they could be like oh we
have video of that we put each of that
and that was the thing and then this is
where it gets [ __ ] up because even
Epstein there's a lot of people who
think he's like a low-level dumb-dumb so
he's groomed into this thing where he
went broke on some other scam and some
other [ __ ] and then they're telling him
okay you're gonna do this because they
had to really it was really cutthroat
the organization man I mean the girls
that were in it were saying that they
were recruiting other girls they would
go to a poor neighborhood have a condo
nearby and then these girls have no
[ __ ] food so there's girls 14 and
then it's like and then they were
expected like you have to get more
people your indoctrinating them into the
system now with him he's bagged by these
other billionaires who I think wanna
[ __ ] these girls but also are like I
have this deal going through with the
Senate let's take him on an airplane
ride hang out take the island now we
have all this dirt on Bill Clinton I
feel like I don't know I mean that's and
I get I don't want to yeah but I would
love but I would love to know you know
like we we there's something clearly
going on there that everyone's trying to
brush over and yeah yeah man I the only
thing I wish conspiracy
would do and then I would be so much
more on your side because I do think a
lot of like official narratives are
oftentimes just like whitewashed to fur
the people in power I wish people would
bring more evidence and have a higher
standard of evidence like yeah in
conspiracy theories it's so much like
there's a question and so they just fill
it in with whatever pre-existing like
the lizard people are obviously like
behind it on and say yeah I'll believe
you if you have evidence but you have
the key to that standard of evidence
they are subjecting everything else to
look and I'll say this about the pickup
artist and I'll say this about the
conspiracy theorist people wouldn't all
hate you like you wouldn't be such a
pariah if you didn't have so many
psychopaths in the in the bunch because
I have met pickup artists at these
YouTube meetups they're nice guys
they're like men's dating code like
they're like they teach losers how to
just talk and like how to ask oh they
literally will sit with someone be like
hey don't text for five times
someone is makeup would need to do that
tell some guys hey keep your game tight
baby I'll teach you oh go I'll go
through what I said I don't think it's
always so bad but then you have a
footage of a guy who basically goes to a
college campus trick some girl
videotapes are until they have sex even
puts that video so now you're all gonna
get painted with that conspiracy
theorists look one out of ten of them is
right did they [ __ ] Navy just put a
UFO footage
[Music]
yeah yeah but the other nine are so wild
dude I was trying to tell people that
they found UFO footage to like two or
three adults on a zoom call yesterday
they hadn't heard of the story they were
all like a Miche calm down I don't about
this one okay so there's this one crazy
scandal that happened I wish I knew the
name of it but it was this like
pedophilia scandal and I just got us D
monetized and D ranked off of all of
YouTube so no one will ever see this
podcast that's okay but anyways there
was this like big scandal where all
these kids are coming forward and saying
hey there's like this like shadowy
organization they led me underground
they had hoods on
and they were like these like satanic
rituals going on and everybody's like
that's just a kid saying that and then
another kid said it and everybody was
saying like all that all the teachers
everybody was just basically just
crediting the kids oh they're crazy they
don't that they don't know anything
nobody believes it later on some
archaeologists goes back like 20 years
later something like that and he goes
let me dig under this this campus and he
finds all the tunnels so like 150 kids
and like one guy or a few guys who
believed him we're all right the entire
time that like this insane thing was
happening but because it sounded so
crazy nobody was willing to believe it
cuz like yeah it's just like truth is
stranger than fiction sometimes anyway
just ladies we don't know we don't want
to believe it and here's what's arraign
they all right sometimes and and here's
a so interesting what the human brain
what the story you just described and I
gotta go in like a minute but the story
you just described literally the
opposite of that's happened to where a
bunch of kids were kind of we're kind of
like Lord met Lord but like talked into
saying they were molested did this is a
real story it's like a real like it was
it was almost like part of like this
psychology study that I saw him where a
bunch of kids were told like something
bad happened to you right and like they
were almost like talked into like the
culture like this mini cultures talked
about your kids into saying that someone
did a thing then they realized 20 like
that was another 20 years later they
realize it's like we all just kind of
got caught up in this hysteria and like
and this is there's a great movie about
this called their crucible where they
talk about the Salem witch trials and
how it just it perpetuates itself
it starts perpetuating itself in
people's terribly and this is a thing
where where a lot of these cult leaders
they need an enemy because a lot of what
they're doing is their indoctrinating
you with like we're this team and
there's this evil out there and as they
tell you that selling the mythology of
their thing yep you'll start bringing
stories of like even a lot of times like
capitalist will be like oh you're a
communist aren't you you want healthcare
you're [ __ ] communist and next thing
we're gonna be in a gulag it's like glue
egg I mean Canada's doing it it's okay
Europe's doing it it's okay it's saving
money the ghoul actor the gulag the
ghoul eggs oh my gosh but dude I do have
to go
we find we went like way over it was fun
it was a black dude let's do this again
for sure I'll come on your podcast and
yeah I can talk forever and we can we
can just respond to new people I can
find people - if you want to ever talk
about another guy dude I would like yeah
yeah let's let's do it we'll hook it up
I'll chat you up again thank you a Miche
guys follow him everywhere fade to brown
thank you so much if you found him funny
on here as I know I did you'll find him
funny on all his social so thanks for
coming on the show and I'll see you guys
see you next time